first of all the character of Doctor
Strange made its first appearance and
strange tales July 1963 issue 110 so for
a character that it's been part of the
Marvel Universe for so long why Kevin
and Scott let's now the right time to
bring you into the Marvel Cinematic
Universe
well it's something we've been talking
about for many many many many years and
sometimes things just work out you know
timing often particularly the cinematic
universe works out well for us and it it
will be our 14th film within the MCU and
we always say we have to push the
boundaries we have to keep surprising
people we have to keep making them
unique and different and certainly this
movie and this character fits all of
that and also tapping into other
dimensions and tapping into sort of a
supernatural realm of the Marvel comic
universe is going to come in handy you
know as we move forward throughout the
cinematic universe so the timing was
perfect
Scott I mean I you know Kevin is one in
green lights the movies so he is the
official answer I mean I think that the
comics is a fan of the comics growing up
with the comics dr. strange was a you
know product of the 60s and was a big
breath of fresh air into into the world
of comics at that time and as a fan
watching movies I I felt ready for some
new daring weird left turns you know in
the world of comic books and the MCU
I think guardians the galaxy was that
and you know I was so pleasantly
surprised when I saw how bold that movie
was so when I came in to meet on Doctor
Strange you know my approach was let's
make this as weird in the MCU as the
comic was in the comic book world of the
60s and that's that's what we tried to
do what are the things that
push to make this movie was the start
time you know when you see a film you
see an actor or an actress in a role and
you cannot imagine anyone else playing
this character you know you got the
right person
and I feel like that is definitely the
case with Benedict Cumberbatch as
Stephen strange and dr. strange but what
what sort of changes that you make to
make sure that you can make this movie
with Bennett well moving we move the
release yeah yeah what we're in was that
Kevin and I talked about about you know
who we wanted in the role mean landed on
Benedict pretty quickly and and just
felt like he was he was right I flew to
London met with them explained the movie
I think I had some of my concept art at
that point and and Benedict really
wanted to do it but he was doing Hamlet
the in theatre in London so we were a
summer release movie so it wasn't gonna
work you know and I came back and I met
with a bunch of other actors good actors
but I just felt like it had to be
Benedict and Kevin to his credit agreed
and so we pushed the the schedule for
him very glad they did yes no I'm just
probably but it's incredibly flattering
it's a it's a weight of responsibility
as well obviously but um it's a great
motivator to try and do a good job and
fulfill you know that the promise
they've shown in you so well they've
given to you I always get that phrase
wrong but you know what I mean it's um
it's a good thing it's a very good place
to start from everyone on stage here to
be part of this Marvel Cinematic
Universe it really is like a family and
I feel like the ghosts all bad for
everyone who was a Comic Con in July
that class photo at the end of the panel
was really awesome yeah so so for
everyone who's new to the MCU here like
what was it what's a really little part
of this
the stain range let's start with you uh
well I mean I was just I was just
thrilled because because of this
incredible track record because of that
you know so much care and attention and
consideration is going to go into the
film before you've even begun so and
that you're going to get to work with
the best of the people the best of the
best in the world what they do so it's
just this like treasure trove of of
talent and you know so I just couldn't
wait to dive into that well how about
how about better didn't tell her the
Scotty for you to what do you think I
keep saying that it's a bit like being
invited to join the circus you get
invited to be the bearded lady or the
painted gentleman or something and and
you may have a chance in the future to
play with a clown or learn a bit of
trapeze or work with the ponies with the
plumes it's really the thing the reason
that feels like a correct way to
describe it is that everybody is so
psyched I mean even the sorceress
supreme Kevin Feige is just the super
fan of all super fans and that's he's
the the master of the big top and it
just feels such a lucky break for
everybody who's working in that circus
top don't you think yeah absolutely
hmm I mean I'm so thrilled to be a
publicist for me growing up as a kid I
was always collecting Marvel Comics and
especially spider-man comics and it's
just lovely to see my investment as a
child is the fruition my adult life and
education so yeah just a wonderful
wonderful time no Matt yeah last year's
fancy James five-star war throwing line
dr. strange to marvel cinematic universe
brick your effort you Sonic oh yeah I
mean can only join these guys it's I
mean for someone who grew up with with
the with the comic books basically half
of my life I was reading comic books and
the other half I was watching Bruce Lee
so so when Scott was pitching this story
for me I think ten minutes within the
pitch he said and that's a lot of
kung-fu and flying stuff as a whoa hold
on we want what bit the kungfu bit come
on
yes it was just it's a childhood dream
coming true it's just amazing that you
at the age of 108 the kitchen
and fly around and just lives like a
hundred eight-year-old I can tell you
that yeah even I do so no it was a dream
coming true I mean it's something as a
kid you were looking at this like
obviously you would never dream about
being up there but you you identified
with the characters right and so yeah
it's a big honor to be it well you know
as a number more than eight years into
the MCU it started with ironed in 2008
it's hard to believe it's been eight
years
so our cabinet for Sky what are the
challenges to to make these films fresh
so they don't fall shackle formula they
don't feel conventionally by superhero
standards that could happen but I feel
like it really could succeed in making
this fresh and different while still fun
and fitting in with the unscalable what
were the challenges with that Scott I
mean the you know the challenge was to
try to make a movie that is as visually
progressive by movie standards as the
the Ditko art was in the 60s you know
those our primary source of inspiration
was the early Stanley Steve Ditko comics
and that artwork is still progressive
you know you look at a lot of the panels
in the comics and and there was a
primary source of inspiration and visual
effects have just gotten up to where we
can do some of the things that we didn't
in this movie
and I think that the trick of it was to
not hold back and to push ourselves as
far as possible to
do original things with the set-pieces I
remember and some of my early meetings
saying that I felt like my that my goal
was for every set piece in the movie to
be the weirdest set piece in any other
movie you know but each one of them
would would be uniquely odd and unusual
and refreshing and that comes out of a
movie fan more than anything else
because that's what I want to see I
wanted I want to see event movies that
use visual effects you use visual
effects sequences for more than just
mass destruction but get more creative
with them and find new ways to do them
and give me as an audience member some
kind of visceral experience that's
unique because the movies that do that
are memorable and change you know and
change the way you feel about cinema in
general and and you know I don't know if
we if we achieve that but but it was
certainly the goal to to push ourselves
into something new in something fresh so
that the audience would be genuinely
surprised in in moments and and get
their money's worth you know yeah I mean
like the special effects were definitely
groundbreaking and like I mean at the
screening I went to one Tuesday and I
ever almost like Wow but the art from
Steve Ditko's panels in the early comics
still had like the circles around dr.
strangers hands and all that so I think
you've really had a good blend but you
know for Benedict when you got all
decked out with the cloak in and just
really saw yourself looked in the mirror
for the first time and saw yourself as a
dr. strange where you like wow this is
cool yeah I was sort of giddy like a
child at Halloween I just I it's that it
was the first moment really properly
Alex spotted it our brilliant designer
who's done a few of these films and she
went oh you're having the superhero
moment yeah
it really was the penny drop moment for
me you know this this film had lots of
alluring qualities lots of things that
made me really want to go to it and this
character in particular and particularly
what Scott and and Kevin were pitching
to me is his trajectory his origin story
and where he was going to lie within the
Marvel Cinematic Universe but the
journey he goes on was sort of supremely
important to me and the qualities of
drama but also great humor amongst that
profundity and that oddness and unique
weirdness and newness that we were going
to bring visually so I'd kind of put the
hero thing on the back burner so I first
had that moment it really was quite
giddy I just did end up just giggling
and then the second time it really hit
home was was was near the end of the the
main body of a shoot in when we were in
New York we were in on Fifth Avenue and
there were as many paparazzi's that were
crew is getting a little bit surreal and
but we're on Fifth Avenue and running
down it and sort of jumping while
skipping really but jumping to fly and
there was the Empire State Building that
in the same eyeline and it was it was
just a moment of magic to think that the
you know the many women that first
crafted these comics on the floors of
some of those of that building and other
buildings and that didn't you go into
Forbidden Planet or you went into a
comic I went into a comic book store
which is the last day shooting in New
York and Scott was just like look I have
not add the video on my phone I've never
shown it to anybody with Benedict it was
alright it was a spontaneous thing he
said there's a comic book store right
there and he's in full so we have to go
in and he goes he goes we should
shouldn't we are gonna film it it'll
just be us and we were getting ready to
shoot he said I said okay and I put the
camera on him and then he just said he
say okay he introduced himself he said
okay I'm about to go into this comic
book store and I followed him in and
entire said think of people who were
there couldn't believe that it was dr.
strange did he die and he bought a
couple dr. strange comics no I didn't
have any money so identify the comics
but I got my services I said look if the
film doesn't work I'll come and snap the
shelves yeah that's right my big bit
heartbreaking like Doctor Strange issue
number 5
I know the cosmic store owner said
that'd be fine but you had to have keep
your American accent that's right I'm
gonna work there which would have
probably amused him as much as he has
but ya know it was it was a magic magic
moment no pun intended it was it was
very special and utterly like a lot of
things in this boom very sort of not
search for they just they came about for
the right reasons it really was the last
place we were starting the last shot of
running away from Massachusetts that
comic book stores in front of them okay
it's what speak for everyone in this
room will you please post that the CCTV
footage has already been posted I'm sure
of that
yeah but I'm talking about the actual
spawn to you and I might can I post it
I'm asking her no that's all right
that's an Headley Benedict for now oh no
no no I thought it was Kevin for now I
was those I was just looking at okay how
did it yeah it's saying what it's all
get up to the audience here who wants to
start with the first question Debbie you
go first
yep Debbie do we have mics yes we do I
had to ask that for Michael
congratulations all of you this is a
real it is a visual stunner is a story
stunner one of the best origin stories
that I have seen in diems in MCU so
kudos to you Scott to Cargill and to you
Kevin for putting all that together
something that I found very striking
very elegant about the film is the hand
choreography in conjunction with the
visual effects for the two Benedict's
Tilda and mads can you talk about that
hand choreography and the elegance and
the precision of it that was required in
order to meld with the VFX well that
hand choreography is a thing called
tutting he had a proper master working
with us for weeks I would say I mean
just as much as learning martial arts we
were learning how to touch with Jay funk
who is somewhere here possibly but if
he's not you should go on YouTube and
look for Jay funk because he really
knows how to do it properly magic
fingers like you know not like our
fingers like real know
CGI fingers and he taught us a series of
extraordinary very precise movements
which have to be super precise because
if you're going to go like that you have
to be at a certain point where the line
is going to be drawn between your
fingers and you can't of course be in
front of your face which was always my
issue I was always in front of it for my
face with it and then you have to be
exactly the right width so that you're
in the frame and it was super precise
and kind of hairy but really good fun
and can we all do it now
possibly not possibly I'm winning I'm
the lower league of and in doober
yeah you didn't have to do much now yet
using is really you bet I get to
practice in front of a mirror yes ever
learned and MJ funk but yeah was it yeah
you're right about it's a great right
about blocking here face there's the
half of my direction destilled it was
her doing things like this and saying
great till they're just lower lower so I
can see your face lower okay but she was
brilliant I'm she's being very humble
about she was incredibly good and also
because she was instructing strange at
the same time I mean there was there was
some quite heavy dialogue going on while
she was you know drawing of Mandela and
punching energy and doing very delicate
start you did runes with brushes and all
sorts of magic stuff but it's such fun
because you have these extraordinary
visual effects directors saying by the
way this is gonna look like this and
they'll show you one shot you'll go it's
gonna look like that and they say yeah
trust us it will and then you kind of
forget that and then if you're lucky
enough as I have to have seen the film
and seen what they did with it it's
beyond anything they warned us it was
going to be and that's kind of why we
look fairly relaxed about it cuz we had
no idea I think if we'd known it was
going to be so awesome we would have it
like that
he's next right over here front Mads
you've played in Bond film he played
Hannibal so you've done these really
kind of iconic villainous characters we
were really relished the villainy so to
speak but here you play a character who
from his perspective he's the hero he's
going to save the world and even when he
kills people and that's kind of a sign
of his villainy it's not really that
different from some of the good guys who
are saying yes we have to kill but it's
to save the world for a greater good can
you talk a little bit about approaching
a villainous role that I mean when you
did it did you kind of come into it just
thinking I'm gonna play this character
as the hero as far as he evenings it's a
story about him like trying to save the
world the rest of them are the villains
well I always play all all characters as
a hero I mean I think we have to look at
it that way I the key to any good
villain in which I think was very clear
from the beginning in this script is
that they have a point it's not
completely creation what they're saying
it's it there is a point even in Doctor
Strange eyes he does believe I have a
point even though it's for a fraction
it's there and and I think that's the
key for good villain you have to have
something the the audience identify with
so it doesn't just go ballistic and say
I'm going to take over the world and
because I can yeah it's fun
you know no this is reason you know it's
young life doesn't make sense you know
and what's your thinking about up there
is honestly just placing us here for a
fraction of time doesn't make sense
so I'm onto something and I think all
good ones should should be there and
obviously it's in the script and Scott
was on that page and so we tried to make
him a man who believes in what he's
talking about a little like yeah the
demagogue Jamestowne Jonestown whatever
he's calling right some somebody who
believes utterly
in every words he says actually I meant
to ask you Rachel yesterday that when
you sign on a play for Christy Palmer
did you like do like a binge reading of
comics to like get back get up to Steve
with all this
I did read it Scott sent a few my way
that I looked at and I looked at UM well
it's she sort of an amalgamation of a
bunch of different characters so there
wasn't one particular place to go to
which I was kind of excited about
because she could be kind of a new
invention in a way um but I mean I yeah
I I looked at a lot of Nightcrawler
because she's in a lot of those and yeah
and and I've been getting up to speed
with cat was really Judy Blume and when
I was off sure it ages she should yeah
I've been kind of getting up to speed
and on on the comic universe but I love
graphic novels I just devour those now
so I love the medium and I think it
translates to film you know just it's
just such a perfect matchup so um yeah
I'm still learning yeah sure yeah that's
always learn yeah ooh snacks whoo it's
cooked yes liked uh yeah right over here
on the aisle Benedict the key to the
Doctor Strange is his the baguette use
his arrogance his confidence smartest
guy in the room and the fall and the
humbling DB goes through is that like
playing Holmes or is that completely
different uh well I'd say that fools
still going on to be honest and in that
particular franchise but um so now I'd
say it's slightly different I mean
there's in the Venn diagram of
similarities there is the crossover of
clever and arrogant I suppose and
workaholic but you know it's strange as
a materialists he's egocentric yes but
he's got charm and he's witty he's liked
by his colleagues he's had relationships
with them he's not yeah he's not this
sort of cut off site outsider
sociopathic asexual obsessive that
Sherlock is so yeah there's a there's a
wealth of difference and he doesn't you
know it yeah he lives in New York and
eeks bagels every night against Silas
that's also different he's a man of the
world as opposed to show up who isn't
what saying that
sorry this next uh yes hike it right
over here in the middle if you can um
Rachel I know you know everyone got to
kind of do some fun stuff did you kind
of want to say hey let me just do it for
a second let me just uh I mean sure not
hearing Tilda talking about now I'm like
yeah I could dig that um but my mom's a
nurse and I did not inherit that gene
it's just why I'm up here right now but
um but I was always fascinated by what
she did because it was so far from
anything I really understood so to get
to delve into the medical side of things
and shadowed he's incredible I met this
incredible female neurosurgeon in
Toronto and we had a great neurosurgeon
on set and I got to go I was given the
offer to go in an evac helicopter and do
a weekend which I'm so sad I had to turn
down because I'm a terrible flyer and I
am really queasy about blood so I
thought I would be more of a hindrance
to that operation than a help
so I declined that but everything else
was super fascinating and in a pinch I
could probably suture someone up now so
and I and it was so nice to wear scrubs
all the time when he was putting that
Pokemon and sweating buckets I was
you're doing your nails
oh yeah that's still waiting so um yeah
I learned a lot on this in a different
way yeah who's next
yes you yeah you right in your hand
right here thank you
my question is for mr. benedict
cumberbatch and in the movie dr. strange
says to the ancient one how do I get
from here to there so who is that one
person for you that you're always
striving to get to their level of
expertise well I wish there was one that
would simplify my ounce of
the truth is I get to work with a whole
cast of them almost every job but this
job in particular was extraordinary mean
everyone on it was helping me raise my
game and in every level I mean you know
rachel's has talked about scrubland
i mean that was that was a very tailed
world and to watch her craft to watch
her scalpel like precision pun intended
with just delineating exactly what was
going on where Christine was in that
moment and and it just it helped map out
an entire world that I knew my character
was shifting away from but had to be
completely invested with hopefully like
the audience's at the beginning and
through the duration of the film where
he crashes back into it from Tilda
trailing this incredible line between
being ancient and wise and yet ever
youthful as she is and just incredibly
now and present and not something old
and fussy fusty and just doing it the
grace and charm and and good nature that
all the cast of this had to to have I've
worked with before again to watch him
construct more dough and see the complet
the complexity of his journey as well
come to fruition I mean all of it and
Mads this man over here complains about
being a hundred but moves like a 20 year
old dreams of moving sometimes you just
is the most absurd athlete but also the
most understated and Supreme gentleman
who is always trying to make sure that
you're right and that your craft is
alright and that you're not getting hit
in the face or hurt you know and that's
that's that's not always the case in
fight scenes to Benny who I've known for
a while we're all Micah's but to get to
play with him as he and I you know I
door one I think the world's going to
absolutely love that character and it
was it was a masterstroke on his part um
and yeah they're the people who I get to
work with every day on a job like this
and then headed by director and a
mastermind who both know their craft
inside out and you feel safe in the
hands of parents I mean this could go on
for a long time this would be bad
I haven't touched on school days yet
you know I'm very I'm very lucky I'm
very lucky I've worked with some truly
inspiring people and a lot of them on
this huge sofa with me snacks ah yes
you're in the end the glasses give yes
hang on wait for the microphone okay for
Kevin and Scott you guys touched a
little bit on kind of the Trippier
sequences you know movie I'm just very
curious if you could talk a little bit
more about how those were developed and
designed and if there was ever a point
where you thought oh this might be a
little bit too far maybe we should back
off a little bit on that I think there
were a lot of those points but we just
kept pushing forward and our amazing
effects team led by steps already did a
great job and Scott was you know in
there right to the bitter end till about
12:30 a.m. that did what we got on the
plane to Hong Kong serious first chunk
it yeah it was you know we because of
because we moved the schedule for
Benedict we had a shorter
post-production Tory really than we
wanted sorry yeah but but but but a
longer - Kevin and loose Ted
credit we hired more vendors than to
start all at once then you normally
would have so we had a lot of the stuff
coming in all at the same time but that
was one of the most creatively rewarding
parts of the whole process was to to try
to think about not just you know weird
bizarre images but to try to think about
what what can't be done you know the
final sequence of the movie was the
result of of me just thinking well what
can't you do you know in this idea of
the fight scene going forward well as
cities undestroyed backwards what you
can't you can't that's impossible
okay great let's do it you know and so
we designed the scene and and storyboard
you know storyboard out things and then
work with the previous team and get it
all down and how we how it looked and
then we figured out how to make it and
so it was about trying to a stat and the
same thing like with what we call the
magical mystery tour the whole mind trip
scene you know it was about drawing out
every single shot
and some of it being impossible to do
and then and and the result was that the
visual effects vendors had to sometimes
help us figure out well how do we do
this because it is unprecedented it
hasn't been done before and and some of
those ideas didn't work and you know
sometimes we would try things and it
just it was that we were we were
overshooting but me personally I felt
like every day I got it for work and I
thought somebody's gonna come knock on
my door and say you gotta back off this
is just getting too weird
you know and it never happened I mean
Marvel was really completely behind the
idea of trying to push the boundaries of
what a set piece intent whole movie can
be and that was always the goal I'm with
you on the Beatles reference magical
mystery tour very good yeah right
blessed Scott Menzel right there first
off I have to say that out of every
Marvel movie so far this is the best
cast hands-down
you guys all killed it so you should
know that not amazing direction yeah um
and this course is directed for Benedict
um in the comic book there's a are about
the Illuminati will that be making a
presence in any of the future films in
the MCU Kevin Feige he is the real
sorcerer supreme so that I really would
pass that question over to him it's not
mine to answer well what's fun about the
Illuminati right are certain characters
interacting with other certain
characters so I don't know about that
particular storyline but certainly some
of those characters you will see
together on on screen in the next
Avengers film is what I was gonna say
okay got time for a couple more uh yeah
right here in the front
yes in this in the sixties this ideas of
alternative universe and open your mind
was very strong and groups like the
Beatles were there so I'd like to ask
you Benedict and
children Rachel the actress who wants to
answer this what about which relation to
see in this world to the themes that
happen in the 60s you do Prewitt in the
movie what about this thing about open
your mind and think about open your
imagination in mind well I wouldn't say
that the 60s had it all I would say if
anything maybe more than ever we need to
concentrate on opening our minds and in
particular to knowing that our minds are
ours to have some kind of perspective on
there's something really radical that's
said in this film which is that ego and
fear are things to be lived beyond and
let's face it this is a hot topic
we really really need people to remind
us right now that ego and fear are not
necessarily the only option we can live
through so I would say yeah the 60s
comes around again but but more and and
stronger and this is such a modern film
for that reason and I would say that's
the reason why it's perfect that it's
made now because it's the time is really
right for it last question I'll go ahead
no I know I think I think I would I
would completely utterly you know
condone what you said you know it's
about mindfulness in a sense I think
that's the that's the the common
derivative which has carried through
culturally we're still referencing that
era we we always will it was a very
strong moment in in all culture and all
pop and music but I think you have to
reinvent the wheel site and you can't
just replicate it this is this is a film
for now
but I think like Tilda was saying the
strongest message is the idea that you
with your mind have the power to change
your reality and that's that's that's a
great wonderful freeing egoless message
and also you do that with the idea of
doing it for the good of others and
you're onto a very very good thing as
Doctor Strange gets to by the end of the
film last question is this the end of
the film says Doctor Strange will return
it's like James Bond right so where will
Doctor Strange go with the Doctor
Strange series but also within the MCU
other films Avengers and so on well I
mean just taking one step at a time
that big puts on the cloak again early
next year in inventors infinity war god
that's all I know
benedict at how how long do you see
yourself wanting to play Stephen strange
oh well you know let's let's get this
film out first
I love these yeah I'm it one of the one
of the things that mindfulness is being
present now you know and I just want to
enjoy today I really really do that
we're bringing this film to the world
properly for the first time this is the
world premiere and it's right for home
town and I'm so excited about I haven't
seen the film yet and if I don't have
too many of these or get a proper nap
okay I will be just glued to my seat I
know I'm good it's gonna bits I can't
wait oh it's a lot this moment saying a
lot it like a dragon I thought we said
that is that the last say it is a latte
yeah okay Skype antic tilta Benedict
Rachael Mads Kevin thank you so much
you